[Music]
last weekend music in theater arts had a
series of events that were happening
they put up a live stream online when a
friend told me our video had like 14,000
views I was like blown away puts
pressure on in a good way to know that
there are that many people watching does
have implicit feel of being a much
larger arena I was like oh greetings
from Rome greetings from Brazil I think
it was great to show people that MIT
wasn't limited to just technology we're
doing arts bless technology my parents
got to watch it which was really awesome
because they live in California so it's
not really feasible for them to fly all
the way out here and so they were very
very happy and send me lots of texts at
the end most of the students who come to
MIT they have a performance background
[Music]
I did not expect this as a high school
student coming to like a science and
math school I kind of felt like I was
almost making a sacrifice of music to
come here and so finding out that
there's so much support and energy and
money that goes into this is really
really wonderful it's pretty young
sublime I guess you could say
you